[Música]
Bienvenidos a Francia en foco su
programa sobre la actualidad francesa la
crisis energética como resultado de la
guerra en Ucrania es el tema central de
esta edición veremos Cómo han
reaccionado los franceses ante la
sobriedad energética que le solicita el
gobierno para disminuir el consumo en un
10%, Qué medidas han tomado de sus
hogares e incluso como han adaptado sus
prácticas deportivas
[Música]
ante los altos costos de la energía que
se creen para 2000 23 aumentarán en un
15% los franceses intentan reducir sus
facturas de gas y de luz ahora con la
llegada del Invierno muchos buscan
opciones alternativas como la madera
para la calefacción esto en la chimeneas
y calentadores veamos el siguiente
informe
vista desde afuera era perfecta pero una
vez comprada hubo malas noticias la casa
consumía demasiada energía
la primera sorpresa fue ver que la
buhardilla no estaba aislada
fue por ahí que maxim bachelet empezó a
reducir su gasto
aquí pueden ver el cortafuegos y la lana
de vidrio para conservar el calor dentro
de la casa y que no se salga por el
techo poco a poco este Padre de Familia
se ha vuelto un experto en el ahorro de
energía por ejemplo aprendió a purgar
sus radiadores para reducir un 20% su
consumo este radiador y todos los demás
se limpian se le saca el aire Sobrante
eso permite ganar eficacia energética
otra obra cambiar las ventanas por unas
con doble vidrio Y aislar las paredes
con estos cambios la familia redujo un
20% el monto de su factura de gas y
ahorra 80 euros al mes
fueron unos 20.000 euros para el
aislamiento y las obras de carpintería
en una casa como ésta pero la comodidad
y el ahorro en las facturas de energía
valen la pena
para la familia la sobriedad se
convirtió en una filosofía de vida
ahorrar tecnología cada vez más escasa
en vísperas de un invierno incierto
según un estudio dos tercios de los
hogares franceses han reducido su
consumo Durante los últimos meses pero
su principal motivación sigue siendo
controlar los gastos se llama
si en algún momento los precios de la
energía empiezan a bajar que puede pasar
la sobriedad Se olvidará rápidamente
en un modelo de negocio el servicio que
ofrecen analizar el consumo energético
gracias a los contadores Linkin para
detectar el mal gasto
y un aislamos y analizamos cada punto de
consumo la calefacción corresponde a un
51% del consumo en modo de reposo 27%.
entonces en términos de sobriedad
realmente hay aspectos por mejorar
según este emprendedor querer reducir el
monto de la facturas puede llevar a un
cambio duradero lo más importante saber
cómo ahorrar a largo plazo y lo que nos
dicen nuestros clientes es que se
prestan al juego una ganancia sustancial
teniendo en cuenta que un cuarto de los
hogares franceses tuvo dificultades para
pagar sus facturas de energía en 2021 la
crisis energética también afecta las
prácticas deportivas es el caso por
ejemplo de las piscinas públicas algunos
han optado por cerrar sus puertas
Mientras que otras para mantenerse a
flote han tomado la decisión de
disminuir la temperatura del agua veamos
en este reportaje lo que ha sucedido en
la piscina pública de noron showman
estoy haciendo un suburbio de París y de
como sus usuarios sean adaptado a la
situación
la piscina olímpica de noroncio Magna
solía tener una agradable temperatura de
26 grados Pero esto era antes de que la
guerra en Ucrania llevara a un alza
estrepitosa de los precios del gas y
obligar a la dirección de la piscina a
detener la calefacción del agua el 15 de
mayo decidimos detener la calefacción de
la piscina de 50 metros principalmente
por razones financieras en septiembre de
2020 el precio del gas era en promedio
de 11 euros por megavatio hora en
septiembre de 2022 el promedio es de 151
euros les dejo hacer la suma pero para
nosotros aquí en nuestra piscina de nos
llame esto representa un ahorro de 45 a
50.000 euros semanales en los meses más
fríos para no dejar de nadar en otoño
algunos decidieron usar traje de buzo
para poder enfrentar el frío bajo el
agua
[Música]
es una dicha de verdad que ese traje es
una gran experiencia no había usado uno
antes pensé que impediría un poco los
movimientos Pero no por el contrario uno
se siente fresco mucho mejor después de
entrenarse con un traje como estos en el
agua fría que en el agua caliente como
acostumbraba
desde octubre el uso de estos trajes de
baño es obligatorio en esta piscina
sobre todo por razones médicas y para
evitar todo riesgo de hipotermia
lo que estamos pensando es que
mantendremos esta piscina abierta lo que
más se pueda hasta que la temperatura se
complique es decir esté bajo los 15
grados centígrados
con estas medidas la municipalidad de
noroncio Man podrá ahorrarse casi dos
millones de euros este año más cuando el
centro náutico representa la mitad de la
factura de luz de la ciudad
tanto las empresas como los hogares
deben reducir su factura de energía
Durante este invierno a los particulares
se les incita a hacerlo sopena de un
eventual racionamiento pero si hay
mayores restricciones para los locales
comerciales y las oficinas sin embargo
para un grupo de militantes ecologistas
los esfuerzos No son suficientes por eso
van en las noches por las calles de
París apagando las luces que encuentran
encendidas a su paso
son las 9 de la noche en París un grupo
de activistas se reúne en una plaza de
la capital para escuchar las
indicaciones de la acción que harán esta
noche Esta es una acción de extinción
por eso no será violenta lo cual quiere
decir que no habrá violencia física
hacia las personas ni tampoco violencia
verbal de ningún tipo este grupo recorre
las calles del centro de la capital para
apagar las luces de los comercios que
quedaron encendidos en la noche con un
palo van apagando los anuncios a un
encendidos y pegan un papel en las
vitrinas donde explican a los dueños de
los almacenes el porqué de esta acción
realizamos esto porque estamos en plena
crisis energética hay riesgos de escasez
de energía y porque el invierno pasado
12 millones de personas pasaron frío en
Francia porque no tenían como calentarse
de manera adecuada Por otra parte se
desperdicia luz con los avisos de
publicidad que consumen inútilmente las
publicidades luminosas de los paraderos
de bus también son apagadas por donde
vaya este grupo en su mayoría jóvenes
que consideran no Solo lo importante de
hablar sino también actuar frente a la
crisis
energéticamente el centro de la ciudad
sin publicidad luminosa es para mí un
progreso Aún si es solo un tipo de
sobriedad es como hacer el duelo de algo
que antes considerábamos como algo que
era deseable
para evitar cortes de luz e incluso un
racionamiento el gobierno pidió a las
empresas tener un plan de ahorro
energético para este invierno en París
la ciudad anunció un paquete de medidas
para reducir su consumo pero para estos
activistas lo anunciado no es suficiente
queremos ir mucho más lejos del opuesto
en marcha porque lo anunciado por el
gobierno es solo la extensión de la
prohibición de las publicidades
luminosas entre una y seis AM en todas
las ciudades de Francia el segundo
problema es que las municipalidades no
tienen medios adicionales para hacer
aplicar esto y el tercer problema es que
entre una m y 6 no es en realidad el
horario en el que hay tensión en la red
eléctrica es más bien entre 6 pm y 8 pm
por eso es que esta medida del gobierno
no va más allá de ser un anuncio de
nuevo es solo una eco impostura de los
políticos para decir estoy haciendo algo
Esta no es más que una primera fase para
crear conciencia según este grupo de
activistas de hecho tras esta acción
algunos comerciantes se mostraron
dispuestos a apagar las luces más
antes de que la crisis energética
golpeara a la puerta a los franceses ya
empezaban a adoptar comportamientos más
amables con el medio ambiente según un
estudio el 65% de ellos ya han cambiado
sus hábitos en cuanto a los medios de
transporte y al tipo de alimentos que
toman sin embargo la preocupación mayor
continúa siendo el consumo de energía en
sus casas la misma rutina cada mañana en
esta empresa de leña para calefacción
los camiones se cargan sin parar ante la
cercanía del Invierno venua bofill
despacha hasta 50 estéreos de madera el
equivalente a 50 metros cúbicos un año
histórico con un aumento de más del 30%.
ha habido un gran aumento desde el mes
de septiembre pasamos de unos 35-40
estéreos el año pasado a 50 55 estéreos
al día donde lo ponemos aquí para este
jubilado la madera es fundamental este
año para contrarrestar la inflación y el
riesgo de cortes decidió apostar por
distintas fuentes de energía acaba de
encargar una Caldera línea tenemos una
Caldera de diesel Y a eso le sumamos
madera para alternar un poco y no
depender tanto del diesel Christian y su
esposa recibirán su Caldera a principios
de noviembre gracias a esta inversión
esperan que su factura de calefacción
baje 500 euros este año
viendo cómo está el precio del
combustible en este momento
y además el calor de la madera es mejor
es agradable estar con un buen libro
cerca de la chimenea en un sofá se está
muy bien
Además cada vez más clientes llaman al
jefe de empresa para desordenar las
chimeneas la demanda está disparada
benoa tiene actualmente hasta ocho citas
al día
deshollinamos mucho para la gente que
quiere volver a poner aparatos de
combustión que habían dejado de utilizar
algunos llevaban más de 10 años sin
usarse
por ahora no hay problemas de
abastecimiento en la empresa Pero al
gerente le preocupa poder cubrir la
demanda para la siguiente temporada
hasta aquí esta edición de Francia en
foco Gracias por habernos acompañado
continúen con nuestra programación en
France 24 y France 24.com